also das erneute Fernbleiben der
bundesinnenministerin sorgt für Kritik
der Opposition hier zu hören wir die
innenpolitischen Sprecher von AFD FDP
und Union nach der Sondersitzung des
Innenausschusses gestern der auch ohne
Frau Faser stattfand
besteht dass er ernste Verdacht im Raum
dass die bundesinnenministerin Weser
versucht hat den
Verfassungsschutz den
Inlandsgeheimdienst zu
instrumentalisieren um eine Entscheidung
von ihr eine falsche Entscheidung von
ihr zu Entlassung bzw Versetzung des
Herrn Schönborn nachträglich
zurechtfertigen das ist ein sehr
heftiger Verdacht der hier im Raum steht
und die Fragen die ist hier zu
beantworten gibt die kann nur Frau Feser
persönlich beantworten sie hat sich
dieser Gelegenheit heute erneut entzogen
wir geraten so langsam an das Ende der
Möglichkeiten mit normalen
parlamentarischen Mitteln hier
Aufklärung von der Ministerin zu
erlangen wir wissen seit gestern dass
sie darüber hinaus versucht eine
Schonzeit Ewigkeiten terminierte
regierungsbefragung der Innenministerin
in der nächsten oder übernächsten
Sitzungswoche zu verschieben und sich
auch hier der Befragung zu beziehen das
alles lässt den Schluss zu dass die
Ministerin versucht alles daran zu
setzen dass sie in dieser kausa nicht
mehr zur Rede und Antwort herangezogen
werden kann und wir müssen deshalb als
verantwortungsvolle Opposition darüber
nachdenken ob wir auch andere schärfere
parlamentarische Möglichkeiten nutzen
wir etwa einen Untersuchungsausschuss um
endlich Aufklärung von der Ministerin zu
erlangen es ist seit vielen
Ausschusssitzung eindeutig klar dass der
deutsche Inlandsgeheimdienst keine
Ermittlung gegen den Präsidenten einer
Behörde geführt hat und dass diese auch
nicht veranlasst werden soll es ist
ungeheuerlich dass der Vorwurf erneut in
dem Raum nun verklausuliert gestellt
wird dies ist in der heutigen Sitzung
eindeutig noch mal dargelegt
so dass wir nun damit konfrontiert sind
dass die bundesinnenministerin eine
Entscheidung getroffen hat den
Präsidenten aufgrund von mangeln
Vertrauen abzuberufen auf eine andere
gleichwertige Stelle zu setzen und ein
Prozess geführt wird um die
Fürsorgepflicht die man möglicherweise
verletzt haben könnte das ist allerdings
in einem Rechtsstaat kein ungewöhnliches
verfahren wir kennen auch andere
Präsidenten von Behörden die umgesetzt
worden sind die Union muss gut aufpassen
dass sie nicht zum falschen
Stichwortgeber geben wird und als
Stichwortgeber gerade diejenigen
stärkt die unseren Inlandsgeheimdienst
sowieso in Frage stellen eine Sache war
ausermittelt wir sehen dann bei der
Ministerin einen gewissen Unwillen
diesen Sachstand zu akzeptieren und wir
sehen sie sachfremd Interesse getrieben
dazu ihre
nachgeordneten Behörden aufzufordern
jetzt weiter tätig zu werden wir haben
nachgefragt wie die Staatssekretärin die
allein anwesend war dieses die Dinge
sein zu dünn es kann derzeit nicht
unterzeichnet werden es soll noch mals
abgefragt werden wie sie das
interpretiert sie verwies darauf dass
nicht weiter abgefragt wurde tatsächlich
sagt der Vermerk wir haben der
Ministerin gesagt dass mehr schlicht
nicht vorliege entscheidend ist nicht ob
eine zweite Abfrage stattfand sondern
das Ansinnen der Ministerin einen
anderen Sachstand zu bekommen als der
der ihr tatsächlich referiert wurde die
Koalitionsfraktionen haben sich in
Nibelungen Treue zu einer fallenden
Figur heute eifert sie konnten aber die
entscheidende Frage nicht klären woher
das Ansinnen kam über den vorgelegten
Sachstand hinaus weiter zu erforschen
mehr zu liefern so nach Art eines
totalitären Regimes an den Geheimdienst
finden Sie heraus das folgendes der Fall
ist auch wenn was bis jetzt nicht haben
das alles ist Amtsmissbrauch im höchsten
Maße diese Ministerin sollte die
Konsequenzen ziehen und ihr Amt dem
Bundeskanzler zurückgeben vielen Dank ja
und eingeordnet und analysiert hat das
für uns noch einmal Emmanuel Richter
Professor für Politische Wissenschaft an
der RWTH Aachen
aus der Causa Schönborn wird jetzt
plötzlich eine causa Feser es ist schon
so dass die Ministerin da unglücklich
agiert hat was mich auch stört ist eben
die Kommunikation auch jetzt von Seiten
der CDU dass man eben sagt das ist eine
Instrumentalisierung des
Verfassungsschutzes die Frage ist
präziser zu stellen nämlich ist das eine
vorermittlung gewesen also eine
nachrichtendienstliche Maßnahme die
Fässer in Gang gesetzt hat oder ist das
nur das Anforderungen eines
ergebnisberichts vom
Bundesnachrichtendienst und dann gibt es
ja noch von Herrn schönbrunnen
einerseits die Klage an Drohung also
dass eben wie er das sagt
beamtenrechtliches Fürsorgepflicht
verletzt worden ist dann gibt es die
Schadensersatzforderungen gegenüber dem
ZDF also diese Affäre ist noch nicht auf
ihrem Höhepunkt angelangt und wird schon
auch für einigen würde sagen und das ist
natürlich kontraproduktiv genau für die
für den Zweck aus dem sich Faser dann
gewissermaßen aus der Affäre ziehen
wollte nämlich den hessischen Wahlkampf
ist ja schon früh kritisiert worden das
Fräser Ministerin ist Bundesministerin
auf der einen Seite und gleichzeitig
Spitzenkandidat in einer Partei in einem
Bundesland wie sollen diese Rollen
miteinander in Einklang gebracht werden
und es wird natürlich wiederum Schaden
für die Ampel anrichten in dem Sinne
dass man eben sagt also da werden
Bundesminister gebraucht die
gewissermaßen 24 Stunden für ihr Amt zur
Verfügung stehen und sich nicht noch mit
anderen Dingen beschäftigen und man
sieht jetzt was daraus resultiert
nämlich ein Durcheinander oder eine
mangelnde Präsenz der Bundesministerin
in den Gremien des Bundes Parlaments des
Bundestags also da können sie schon so
ein paar Fallen ergeben die am Ende
Stimmen kosten in Hessen